this elevator is out of order
sorry
if it's out of order why are you here
out of order for carrie uridine's guests
too
he's expecting me in that case
enjoy your evening
oh
[Music]
old friend met him walking in memphis
off field
inches ago hey it's got prim
stuff might be interesting give you a
friends and family discount too
of course mr eurodyne special rate for
your friends
well let's see what you got now you can
talk this later
come with me i want to show you
something
later spectre
speaking of what's up with us cracks you
can't go
near him so what hit on kovacic
very funny but yeah
not about to let him get away with it
maybe not today
i guess kovachic's got you wrapped
around his little finger
see i thought he was representing me not
the lady
[ __ ] was i wrong nothing you can do
about it
wipe them
they ever want to plaster my face on
baby helmets they can
you try to get out of that deal with the
label ah
let's be real say i break contract
then what who's going to release my new
tracks
who's going to deal with distribution
promotion influencers
media labels have got them all in their
pockets
you're out with them you're out period
you'd be free
seriously free to sing until you're blue
in the face
nobody hearing a thing it's just another
kind of cage
show you one of my favorite spots in
night city don't come here often but
when i do
it's important should i feel special
maybe told them to shut the place down
for the day
can't get enough of this view love
looking at this city from above
well only place you fall asleep thinking
you're special
then wake up knowing you're no one
carrie i can see something's eating you
i thought the whole lost cracks thing
was me being afraid
being exposed people finally seen
me as another piece of merch another cog
in the corporal machine
sell out urine showing asian pop
starlets a good time for cash
fame and a chance to remind people he's
still [ __ ] alive
no truth to that there is
but that's not what's important real
problems deeper
way deeper
talk to me see
thought i was afraid everybody think me
another corporal slave
but i was just afraid i'd be in
someone's shadow again
again lived in johnny's for years
part of the scenery machinery helping
him shine brighter
never believed i'd make it on my own
without silver hand
that's why he left samurai [ __ ]
but you did make it big too
only die hards remember samurai now
you everybody knows your name
you think that changes anything wake up
with the same thought
every damn day that i might somehow fade
in this town's steam stench merc
for good night cities the city of
shadows
done everything i could to walk clear of
him for years
it's time you stop being afraid you
don't need to be
think you could drive the shadows away
you'll be fine without me too
[ __ ] yeah i sure hope so
we should get back coming downstairs is
waiting
for you i know i know
in the knock back a few to this town
tonight and
me in it but i'm gonna stay up here a
bit longer
you got it okay
see